e aí ganha jogando você espera que sim
porque como está tudo ótimo porque eu
não estudo porque não tem um final de
ano escolar para mim porque eu não
estudo mais você estuda em final de ano
pra mim na minha escola era terrível
porque não dizer assim nunca fui
daqueles anunciados só tira zero isso a
tiros em rádios equipe ano nossa meta
sempre ganha aqui no nota nota 8 só que
o meu problema não sei se é com edson de
muitos de vocês que eu tenho um grande
problema em deixar tudo para última hora
só pessoa que eu vou viajar bonito que
identidade passagem amor vai entrando na
vida pessoal escova e tento a 'limpa'
poeta ou especial completa exatamente o
tipo de pessoa que vai para 15 é o tipo
de pessoa que esquece das coisas que
pode maior a emodina a dormir 12
fevereiro no âmbito do g consumo na sala
bota que amam tira só o som é químico do
levante até agosto o ângulo o meu deus
sei quantos trabalho pedir agora no
final do ano eu pois forçada ocorra de
toninho se botava o walkman na minha
frente eu transformo 273 somente um
grande problema que eu quero aos
professores quando estudava antes
marcava eu não sei o que te pegar no meu
pé eu sempre pensava assim não vai ser
um prodígio esse menino é um game faz
seu estilo de obras para pegar no pé
dele é tipo assim jorge fez o dever de
casa para os eua no final estava
passando e eu a patroa e as crianças e
eu queria assistir do bem já walter ser
dever de casa mas somente funcionam no
feriado de carnaval que eu dormi chamada
toca a bola e eu acho que é bem melhor
jogar bola que estudar tá certo voltar a
sentar e tem neymar
aí nem mata provasse da iria ser dever
de casa professores assim o ofício que
será administrada sei que incomoda um
pouco sim a ver com estar menstruada no
peito estava doente mental na verdade
faço muito isso também incluindo essa
renda de cada professor em professor
infelizmente não deu pra fazer porque eu
estava ajudando meu vôo a colocar o boi
na roça tirar leite de manhã que o meu
voto 185 ele pode enfrentar vai forçar
que ajudar eu vou falar essas coisas eu
filho isso não é desculpa ele não é
desculpa perfeita e você tem que fazer o
dever quando eu falo que sou fácil fácil
de ver
um bebê com até o aqui meu filho você
acha que você vai ser o que você faz com
que fosse acontecer o que afronta a
cabine fotográfica youtube não dá
dinheiro na o seu merda é essa marcação
comigo não sei o que é mas é uma pessoa
que eu corri atrás dava certo graças a
deus não tem muita gente que quer provar
o senadinho e tem muita gente tira muito
alto mesmo eu tenho uma técnica para sua
mãe nunca ficar zangada com você quando
você tira nota baixa
você tem que trabalhar muito só teatro
ao todo mundo recebe a nota 7 88 e mail
7.37 todo mundo e sempre pra cima o
índice chega vai preencher vagas em
tremembé gala peruana 36 tuta que para
tirar 15 a 15 thoretton da passei não
que o ponto 3 nem como é que vai
explicar a mãe muito fácil eu falei você
tem que trabalhar seu lado teatral
você chega passou mal e foi mãe pontinha
que lindo dia hoje não tá mais jovens a
pintou o cabelo assim mais viva por mais
vivo é você pergunta se ela pintou o
cabelo pelo amor de deus não diz a cor
da tinta que a gente percebe que a mãe
da gente vai ficando fé andré pinto o
cabelo ea casa em toda a minha juve x
você tem que observar a mãe de vocês têm
que conhecer muito de você duas coisa
que irrita a mãe da gente saber pela
boca de alguém que ela está ficando
velho e quando as mães compram esmalte
pra elas mandam pra rebu em formação do
amor eu fui parecida o que gosta rebuy
massa amorim doador é igual se
identifica pediu você comprar recursos e
pode comprar maçã do amor tira o rótulo
e léo naquela olha eu disse pra eu
comprar rebuçados garfe lindo mas o
cabelo além do oge bem preto vivo no sof
caso que coisa nem é essa em rebu mim tá
ótima é o seguinte agora é a hora é até
que você tem que levar o resto da vida
você chega para sua mãe nos olhos dela
higgs muito aqui
na prova de matemática e eu tirei 36
agora você vai dizer em alto e bom som
para entender mas mãe foi a maior nota
da sala que ela vai pensar dentro dessa
prova tão difícil tão difícil a maior
nota foi 36 e foi do meu filho você
comente aqui embaixo que você mais odeia
em final de ano escolar se você está no
youtube aqui e gostei está no facebook e
clique em curtir está no twitter e dar
rt time está na sua divulgação do estado
não curte a foto você não perde nenhum
vídeo meu canal é só ficar inscrever-se
aqui embaixo e valeu galera tomara que
vocês passeando ou não
valeu então